welcome to this video round nine of
Tatas to 2014 and nine already means
that we're nearing the end of the
tournament it's only eleven rounds this
year contrary to former years when we
had thirteen rounds so on it really gets
to the decisive stages now okay
let's um let's start with today's
coverage I'm this time um soaring the
games a bit differently and start with
Nakamura against Fabiano Caruana and let
me choose this game and we get a vegetal
variation of the Kings Indian green part
this is now blacks choice what is he
going to play it's gone for c5 so not a
typical Kings Indian setup with d6 + e5
and it's also not a goon fault with d5
so we are going with c5 this is in fact
an interesting move order also one move
earlier is interesting I played this one
on yet in more than one game what is
blacks idea yeah one idea is that if
white goes d5 black has quite an
interesting choice IAM he can even
consider to transpose into a kind of
banker gambit or just go d66 go for the
modern be known if you cheat a variation
and this line has some additional points
and we see one of them the camera does
not want to advance he just develops and
after thus captures Khurana plays the
very direct move Queen c7
at taking of the Seaforth home yeah and
in fact white needs to take care of that
if he sacrifices the pawn this is very
questionable if he gets enough
compensation for example after they move
like castles black can really take it
sometimes in the English hopefully you
can sacrifice it for but normally this
happens in positions where black has
played ecigs
and white has some compensation on the
dark squares here this is obviously not
possible and black in general to solve
any square weaknesses in the center like
d66 it's questionable compensation
really white needs to look at the pawn
and he covered it with in the scam he
covered it with b3 after which black has
an interesting move available
he played d5 this at first looks a bit a
bit surprising because d5 is a square
that white controls very nicely still it
is possible the easiest move to check is
of course he takes d5 does check this
piece hanging so not working and the
other move you need to check is Knight
takes d5 however after Knight takes this
is still a problem after this check
again very embarrassing and after the
bishop move black place ecigs
attacking the bishop and after the
retreat after you create and the
possibility five white is just losing
this Knight a very unlucky situation
this means that you cannot really take
it I mean Bishop t5 theoretically
speaking but this is a very ugly move
like has more than one interesting
continuation one is Bishop h3 from
example preventing cancels and this is
just a very silly position of the Bishop
black can also considered to just take
it at the right moment yeah basically
this is the move that white should play
and my camera went for it
Queen a5 Bishop d2 yeah attending the
discovered news and now like retreated
so black has played three Queen moves
then the opening usually this is not so
advisable moving it so often but in the
meantime White has not accomplished much
she's got the bishop on d2 developed the
nights here are not ideally placed
especially considering that if we look
at what happens here the night couldn't
retreat to divorce the Queen is
controlling the square and needed to go
to a3 yeah this is in fact a known
position for example if we at this
moment look at the move Bishop f5 this
has been played in kramnik against raja
baath and london candidates this is one
known example all knight c6 this has
been played before also here in the game
92 which should be six attacking the
weakness here this has been played in a
game kismet tool in against Erie in the
Rhodes European Club Cup last year so we
have unknown territory but whites now
place a difference not 93 he played
rugby 1 so counter take him so how to
sum up this position yep both sides can
attack Bighorns the b-pawn this week
it's on
half-opened befoul and of course the sea
for porn is also very weak and to be
honest it looks to me that those two
weaknesses basically cancel each other
out and in the game we see that after
Luke see 893
if white would take this is a possible
move black regains the pawn and has a
very nice position with the knight being
on c4 so taking is not a good idea and
white prepares that and now grabs this
is an attempt to to complicate matters
really he gives up the strong bishop on
g2 from on and yeah black cannot really
take him and he can but I think what he
played this is superior this kind of
lines may be somewhat more active for
for white he played Bishop a3 and later
went for the centralization and I think
this is a very good play by black it's
simply activating pieces this Bishop is
very annoying always yeah keeping the
the White King alert so that the queen
of the long diagonal something like that
can easily happen and the back rank is
also weak and white really has no
coordination to to push the C pawn or
make any substantial headway it seems
that none of this was saying it seems
that black simply has fine compensation
for the pawn he doesn't mind the trade
actually further enhances the bishops
and after the 93 is gone
c4 is
becoming much weaker in fact I think
we're already in a position where yeah
it must be a bit more cautious in
comparison but okay it's not like why
doesn't travel but he needs to be be
precise I think black black plays
relatively straightforward queen chief
for now f3a no black took on the one
this is a neat little Intermezzo of
course white cannot take here because
I'd be sure to default check okay do
something so that the end get mated
quite quite nice with the bishops yeah
of course after rook takes t1 white just
needs to recapture check yeah keeping
keeping the position actor taking taking
here check at the end does not work now
the bishop here is exposed and cannot be
saved as a distraction yeah you you
can't continue this line if you like you
can go here something like that this
still is very problematic for blanket us
now Bishop before threatened and
something check check like that does not
really help sum it up you shouldn't take
him check what he played after night f2
is much much easier bishop f8 this is
threatening or intending to to activate
this piece and use this this pin
27 and now we just decided to simplify
matters and make sure basically to to
get it wrong right now plays an
interesting try played Bishop to be form
but it does not not really help much
like took and now it takes on a three
it's still problematic for why to make
any headway the night is just not a good
piece and C form it's still very weak
like now played a good move with age six
covering their porn g5 square so that
white cannot easily activate the night
and this is a weak point
anyway after nine F to the shop c5
pinning route III check and this we got
to a weekend game where after a three
here black needed to decide to go for
more passive defense on active defense
very often in the row grant game you
should go for active play however here
it is not necessary to consider any
sacrifices of the a6 born to or to
activate the rupiah you can just just
cover and after this we see that why
it's really does not have any options to
activate the King and this is basically
the decisive factor here that prevent
white from making any sort of progress
they continued for a while actually but
there is not much going on white enjoys
a symbolic advantage because of space
but there is no no real
opportunity who wanted to win the game
you could look a bit and you could
analyze this a bit deeper but I I have
limited time in the video and it's just
very very Jewish and in fact after a
couple of more moves they agreed to a
draw yet I come where I even got the
apron but like just has too much on the
plate
check-check yeah you can you basically
can give check all the way and otherwise
you would pick up one of those phones so
this seemed to me yeah like a very very
correct draw it never ever was
substantial for for one of the players
okay the next game report against Doreen
and yeah you already know this Hungarian
GM is very creative after 9 f6 he went
for Bishop f4 so very early deviation
and it does not yeah it first looked
like much Bishop f4 the London system
and notoriously yeah we can really say
that boring opening very often it leads
to rather dry positions yeah I sometimes
play it myself
especially in blitz games because the
simplicity of positions are sometimes a
good weapon against certain players
however in this game we see that there
is no drawer or anything at all or dry
played the Givi wind went for c5 this is
of course a sharp move immediately
attacking the pawn and another idea is
that the Queen here quickly joins the
action if white plays a standard move
like yeah let's say III for example then
there is Queen b6 to consider I'm not
saying that it is great for black but
white needs to consider the possibility
that his biforn is coming
the fire this is a constant issue once
you develop your bishop early and so on
it's quite similar in the drop off ski
for example here him there's also Knight
c3 for example so it's very interesting
plane but this isn't this did not happen
report in fact immediately went his own
way and took on c5 just taking the pawn
and this immediately leads to from
complications because this pawn yeah how
do you get it back I mean normally those
captures are answered by a six and
Bishop takes e5 but here yeah on the
especial b6 and it's not so clear that
black is going to get the ball back
without any any problems so yeah how do
you actually get it back I give replay
tonight a six not illogical at all
trying to get it with the night but now
report went for Queen deform and just a
very very unusual position you know
we're playing chess here from move for
this is quite nice to see there's no
preparation or deep computer stuff they
just play a game here and yeah it leads
to interesting play check here we go
gave this cheque he wants to get the
porn back obviously 93 and 95 getting
getting it back yeah now we see an
interesting direct flame Bishop d2 is
played
yeah voluntarily voluntary retreat but
it threatens something 94 a discovery
and yeah giving needs to react to that
this is simply threatening to win
material and he played 96 attacking the
Queen and that went to h4 yeah not not
much else really
in terms of logical squares or active
squares and now g5v on note that the
queen is protecting from the side and g5
of course dear Windsor move my tempo
against the Queen moved again and now d5
try to occupy the center of course g5
this is a bit of an untidy move move it
it's it's an oem yeah it's also a bit of
a weakening off the Kings side but it's
it's very dynamic winning a temple and
Bishop g7 can be a good development but
ok first e5 shows that black is going to
play actively in the center but this is
a media immediately answered by a very
active reply with e4 report fights for
the center and yeah well black if black
captures well this is completely out of
the question
attacking the Queen and after de this is
also 94 so the capture on on e4 is not
really earth to to blacks benefit he
went for D form instead and yeah well
now we get very weird complications chat
which paid the check this should be
seven de me reply basically
chant after the capture Knight takes you
don't want to put the King in the middle
of course white went 95 has a very very
strange position where the knight on d5
is very actively placed and not so easy
at the moment to dis much because the e6
Knight is blocking the e pawn so this is
really a strong piece on d5 the only
drawback is that after Queen c5 and this
is what give me plate yeah black is just
attacking on c2 and it's yeah you don't
really have an attractiveness to cover
the poor so on yeah move like oopsie one
or another Queen move is really not not
helping much
so a report goes for a four shot movie
just gives it up 93 Queens two and
castles this is a very straightforward
way to play them I'm pretty sure that
lots of strong players will yeah what
would go for that simply because it
mobilizes our forces and make sure that
you have GAF active play you're not
defending any weaknesses the weak point
you just gave gave away but you're
you're left with with activity though so
this is the most important thing note
that the king is Salone aid yeah here
Gary took on e4 and this seems to be the
right decision it's a greedy but
probably correct it's it's not easy here
would like to to just let's say play a
catch-up game in development and try to
somehow get yeah get the King secured
let's say ship g7 for example what just
takes here and has direct threats and
some yeah black black must be must be
good here this is why queenie force is
the best move but the texts also denied
IAM sad white basically needs to do that
he had to know square to retreat the
night oh so we have the straight now
let's say first yeah it looks like it's
raid but white is this rookie one
intermediate move of course what does
black doing Queen d5 and now he took it
yeah you could could have checked them
other other squares I mean where where
else could let go could go to c6
but then there's rooks e1 you're not
really saving the PCM let's have a look
at the game after Queen c7 it's really
um yeah urge enough like
needs to get get out of the center u6 is
what he played and yeah I played the
sharpest move again
taking on on default yeah this is of
course only possible because of this g5
move we see that after Queen takes this
is what black played he needs to do that
probably I don't really see a another
move on alternative white is just yet to
active here in the center attacking
something like this bishops III rook t1
and the discoveries is very strong so he
just took it and this is also the right
decision Bishop c3 yeah secure Queen c5
and yeah the Queen does not have any
square so it's it's a queen trade yeah
like a Sun Exchange down for the moment
but of course I have a look at the
Bishop after f6 black has trapped the
bishop and it's difficult to secure it
to save it you can you can try but King
f7 will probably pick up the the bishop
anyway and I think what report is doing
now is also the right the right decision
I first note that this is only not good
because it wins the tempo very important
temple so this is Lawson like as an
excellent shape report black rook C 1
and this I think a good a good choice
king is hell this is now was threatening
and Charlie played Bishop takes f6 this
is a funny-looking move but it's
basically simplifying the position
enormously
yeah black needs to recapture the sleeve
yeah well this is
completely crazy giving white an extra
exchange so King f6 they only move and
now I played rookie d1 yeah attacking
the knight if the knight moves somewhere
then this is saying again giving white
an extra exchange so hmm
what is flex means cannot play this one
yeah let's say there is only one who
basically black protects the night and
now white being a rook yeah he's playing
with a rook against two two minor pieces
so why should take the chance to
simplify it takes only seven takes on c5
this was played and yeah we now have
rook endgame where white has a tiny
symbolic edge do two legs slightly
compromised pawn structure but to be
honest there is not much going on every
decent player should draw all that as
black they yeah they try it for a long
while but it it's really very dry and I
don't want to look into this junk in
more detail I mean this is really a very
draw okay you could analyze it more
deeply but then it gets gets very long
check so yeah just quickly go through
the moves
what is always enjoying a little bit of
something because of the better pawn
structure but there's really no no
headway to to make so of them I think
about six moves 60 they like we do to a
draw yeah and this is completely dead
and here we see a very typical
transformation where black at some point
here gives away the pawn to activate the
position especially the King
so I'm a very correct draw I think with
both sides playing them playing a very
good very good game okay next one in the
list is I am my ditch against Harry
Krishna okay let me pull this up yeah
and we um we need to know that NIDA CH
is having an a real terrible tournament
tournament he's on on - I don't know a
lot - five - six it's it's really a
really terrible event and in this game
against high Krishna is playing a really
uncommon opening night see three already
as is very rare and normally I'm the
white now continues with Bishop g5 the
support very soft opening really really
uncommon choice but well it cannot be
terribly bad it's basically employing
the ideas of the chigorin defense to the
Queen's Gambit with an extra tempo so
it's it's certainly not worse for white
however Bishop f4 was played knowledge
didn't go for Bishop g5 which really
makes some more sense to me as it builds
up a possible PIN of on g5 any move of
the pawn for example preparing castling
is this a pin and on an f4 it's not
doing much we see that after Bishop f5
he played f3 and hmm yeah I have my
doubts about that it's um well you've
never ever played before here like it's
controlling the square very reliably
this might prepare g4 but itself feels
like maybe I should just play a three
push of d3 and and develop you cannot
expect much here anyway and this looks
more realistic to me by plate f3 and
went for very quick long castles and I
think that Harry Krishna's reply is
that's very interesting
he played 96 this was was a bit
surprising to me but looking at the game
it it makes some sense the idea is that
a quickly night before can be really
tricky now attacking the c2 pawn with
the white having canceled long this is
not so easy to defend yeah
Queen e1 was played probably preparing
possible rook d2 way to cover c2 and
maybe this queen is preparing me form so
you need a prophylactic move with Bishop
g6 what happens if white no place afore
and I didn't do that but what happens
this is what he played if he plays
before him black can also just castle
and later prepare activity on the Queen
side Queen and Knight a5 to see form can
also be an idea and only later the C
pawn is used
um it's and everybody have some there's
some issues with White's play it simply
does not don't look does not look right
to me yeah I played Knight h3 castles
and Knight f2 probably preparing this
but after Knight h5 this Bishop was
attacked and yeah wet where to put it
you cannot go here it's just giving away
the all-important fault and after Bishop
g3 yeah black hand amongst others just
take it and gain the bishop pair while
weakening
dark squares on in whites camp it's not
helpful at all he decided to keep the
bishop and go to e3 but this is very
honorable yes and when you get this
bishop it's just not doing anything
her Krishna place is very nicely night
before taking here rube T 2 and now C 5
this is of course very important the
pawn must be used to a tec-9 Center and
it also allows the Queen to to join the
game after G form he just retreated of
course and after H 497 this is all very
nicely played the knight can regroup
here and white
yeah well whites play only makes sense
in connection with h5 really but this is
not a move that display oh well I can
just take him and this leads to leads to
absolute disaster for example if white
captures cm this is a very very naughty
pin for sorry probably here and then
like just takes him and detects the
Queen yeah and something like that for
example is this totally hopeless
whereas this Bishop going yeah what
loses a piece so um yeah why this
essentially busted here already and
after f4
he played Bishop f6 going here to
increase the pressure on deform 94 yeah
and this is now a forced win there was
also Knight c4 but there are many ways
to to get a great position here you just
took him and yeah well we first need to
briefly check this one check check
is this terrible I mean it it's really
really not a nice picture for white yeah
it took on v6 and after the simple
recapture it turns out that why this
attacked here and what is the smooth
he took here after night h3 and the King
bee to black whoever has a very simple
solution he played Queen d6 and this is
threatening Queen a3 with a quick mate
and in fact mate is already unavoidable
here so a really terrible loss for for
night it was certainly very frustrated
with the course of the tournament still
it might be more yeah let's say
professional to just play some yeah some
boring games to two at least
yeah keep some rating points this kind
of yeah setup really am it's just giving
away the point rather easily I guess and
hi Krishna was I was glad to to collect
this okay let's go to the next game
let's go to Galvan begins to Mingus
Galvan also having a bad tournament not
not winning much I think I think it he
hasn't won a game yet if I'm not
mistaken but he lost the couple and
really does not she seem to be in good
shape
the mineus is playing a good tournament
he's in one of the guys that with the
optimal play might even catch Aronian so
when he born game we get a good result
and doming is this a regular group of
player while Gelfand is also playing the
goon for the splack but also for a long
time is now
as a player who fights the roof
unsuccessfully in this game we see girl
from playing the Bishop d2 line still on
somewhat of a sideline against this
opening but it recently gained some
popularity where it has found some ways
to make this testing system Domingues
plays a very year straightforward system
it took on c3 this for years has been
considered to be somewhat yeah the
second-rate continuation because after
Bishop c3 it was thought that this trait
which very likely is going to happen we
see that after yeah it was always
thought that this is not very advisable
for black to trade this important bishop
of course and 7 yeah somewhat were pride
of blacks
set up the the fianchettoed Bishop but
it turns out that in concrete terms the
street the straightest is not a problem
at all in the game we see that Dominguez
is quickly attacking the center white
builds up earn a really broad center
with their form and Dominguez is
attacking it quickly typical for the
goon fault this giant b5 typical dynamic
goon from move he does not want to play
a little passive moves but wants to be
active Calvin took it
no no big choice after this IDI 97 was
played and yeah what is blacks
compensation
yeah blacks compensation lies in the
fact that white with lots of poor moves
especially a for him has weakened many
squares the e-file is weak
and he's not really well developed note
that the king is still in the center so
um after the trade I think this makes
sense it's uh it can easily happen that
the knight gets activated here and the
bishop is not a very useful defensive
piece so I think this makes some sense
to take it Bishop takes Knight f3 black
played Bishop b5 so we can sum up that
black can sacrificed upon in the opening
but the compensation lives and those in
those weaknesses pawn weaknesses and
square weaknesses to be honest I think
that both players really a played an
excellent game here that it's not very
exciting but it seems that it's almost
impossible to suggest a substantial
improvement also the computer does not
really really find find anything great
it at the end boards two words down to
the to the fact that the deep horn is
not supported at the moment by the C
pawn and the knight on f3 is just
non-negative pieces just looking at
squares that are controlled and it
cannot be used at the moment to support
the extra pawn in the center like it's
just increasing the pressure on d5 and
gets it back and effect after this I
think maybe in some some other event
they already could have agreed to a draw
it continues for a while here but black
is just far too active to being in any
trouble here black even has a slightly
better pawn structure but it's
completely completely equal because of
the the rook is not being very active
yeah I can show the show the rest of
this yeah let's say it's quite quite
funny the rook cannot really I mean
black cannot
benefit from the from the extra phone
white will always get it back and here
they agreed to a draw you are not a very
exciting game but I think girlfriend was
probably okay with just playing a safe
draw after all those losses it's um it's
really quite a typical way to to play as
black in the goon fault there's no use
in playing any any passive setup so
something like b5 is very good motif to
remember to break up the center and gain
time in order to to fight whites
pawns him so a fine game by both players
really it's nothing great for the
spectators but this is very often the
case if there are not many mistakes
being made yeah think of a typical game
more for football or soccer both players
both if both teams are playing on a very
high level sometimes don't have the most
exciting games it's more interesting if
mistakes are being made and something
dramatic happens okay next game Wesley
so against Luke invaded yeah from really
having a good event here already
scored scored two wins in the last round
and he goes for the Kings India against
Wesley so slight surprise when Vania has
played the Kings Indian in his youth but
only rarely plays it nowadays he's more
known as winning against the Kings
Indian actually with very sharp lines in
the classical yeah speaking of the
classical Kings Indian we quickly
reached the the main line of the
classical with Wesley so playing the the
court
variation with 91 and Bishop III yeah
this is the absolute main line of the
night II one classical with Bishop III
this is very often named after Viktor
Korchnoi the the yeah a living legend of
of chess who's played this line numerous
times and he always believed that this
is yeah I think he's going so far to say
that this is the refutation of the
opening and yes got many very impressive
wins but it's of course not a refutation
of the Kings Indian but it's a very
tough way to plane of course for black
simply because White's pieces always get
towards the center head at the center
the Queen side and it almost for sure
means that white will break through on
the side of the board and black really
needs to do or die approach and never
made on the Kings side yeah in fact
Wesley so has played this numerous times
before and he has a special line here he
plays G form this is not seen so often
and to be honest I'm quite surprised
that this is a rare move it seems to be
quite interesting with g4 he tries to
yeah preempt blacks on g4 idea and make
sure that blacks attack is not coming so
quickly
um yeah black could take on g3 on the
saw but after the capture it's not clear
how is proceeding with with any attack I
think this is very helpful for white
also note that now f5 is a weakness so
white maybe can use this route for a
good night repositioning taking us not
good
what fun very plays I think at the
is perfectly alright age five is three
and now quickly getting a look on the
edge file yeah then the delicate thing
about this opening at this position in
particular is that that white and black
in some respect as well
it's a balanced defensive moves with
active moves of course you need to crash
through on your on your side black on
the kingside trying to make the king and
white on the Queen side but you also of
course need to pay attention to what's
happening on the other side so we need
to combine attack and defense and I
think they both do a good job p.m. white
activates the night to prepare c5 and
manages to play the support breakthrough
yeah black now takes on c5 this is
always an interesting decision how
should you go about that taking us not
the most common decision but it seems to
be okay here
if black allows whites to take this is
maybe um yeah maybe too slow I mean Roxy
one night be five to seven is coming
quickly in fact I think then really is
playing this perfectly okay it leads to
two very very sharp plane Bishop c5
Knight to g6 of the night near the king
rooks e1 and Bishop to f8 and in fact
this is quite quite remarkable if you
compare this to for example the game of
today report against Geary where they
were on unknown territory on before we
here have a novelty on move nineteen
then really is playing a new move here
and he deviates from two games that
Wesley so has played him with white in
2012 and 2011 he had this position where
black took on g4 and yeah that two
interesting play as well but Bishop
evade is a is a new eidm might be five
directly going for them for the weakness
and now Bishop d6 you're blocking the D
pawn and yeah if you manage to sort of
cut your losses on the queenside then
black is in red really good shape okay
Queen b3 yeah this can be a factor black
needs to be cautious about that and the
queen is also quite often a good
defensive piece on the third-ranked when
Willie took and the rest is so we
captured with the F pawn this is not
seen so often you would normally have
this type of recapture and it seems to
be playable it's not losing or anything
but I kind of like this idea to use the
third-ranked to defend the H pawn and
not easily allow blacks rook to to enter
way to Queen e7 this is combining attack
and defense defending those squares but
also trying to activate the Queen to
increase the pressure on the h-bomb it
takes and 97 now this is very M very
principled grab the material you know
and you again and here we have one of
the in fact many critical positions
Queen h7
is I think very logical and not
debatable it's a text the weakness here
and if white just grabs now on c8 you
could take care
then rook takes h3 is really a very
strong this is a very strong threat so
something like this for example is even
answered by a knight edge for black it's
just a deadly attack here no real way to
prevent that note that it's not only
this capture is also route g3 check so
Knight takes CA this is not possible
okay see it that's basically the same
thing it's not helping for white at all
to to grab the piece yeah but what to TT
we cannot really take the piece it seems
there's only one group C 3 covering H 3
securing against this the stretch and
here black has more than more than one
interesting move and it seems that yeah
they are all playable and quite often
need to a draw I mean if I say they are
all playable I can briefly show you a
couple of ideas hip like for example
could have played when various move was
perfectly okay but he could have played
even the simple capture Yanis have not a
very obvious choice but he could have
done that rook takes can check and then
just retreat here
the point is that yellow this is the
threat now and what is why it's supposed
to do we can play an active move like
we'd be six
after which them of course black is
breaking through him threatening Luke g3
with them at least the perpetual and
yeah white can do any kind of firework
here like yes check but this is only
good enough for a drone it's simply not
possible to to to easily defend against
this attack instead of Queen b6 here it
can also consider a passive defense cook
c3 but this is an important point
actually if always hanging and black
will take that getting two important
pesos and in the center no ticking on a
seven was playable or no doubt another
interesting choice would have been
Bishop to d7 this is just attacking the
knight now and yeah the only sensible
moves now is the queen bee seven
grabbing another pawn after which black
probably plays rook evade possibly
supporting they have pawn to to go even
more forward yeah and this is of course
a very rich position to analyze black is
two pawns down but all pieces are taking
part in the attack while those two
important pieces are yeah well sort of
distracting black a bit it's not like
they're completely out of play but
they're rather far away from the King
side and it seems that blacks should
have enough play to probably secure draw
but this is no exhaustive analysis it's
certainly possible to look at this in
much more detail just one line to show
what happens if white plays Bishop b5
the ticking here may be trying to force
for further exchanges yeah black in fact
can't ignore the d7 bishop and just take
him and this is again good enough for a
draw after 27 like a squinter age form
and this is brilliant
too much to handle if what now takes
this Redis is enough for draw check and
now we need to meet this night - yeah -
to have enough pieces to to secure the
draw not at all easy to calculate but
what I'm trying to show us that there's
more than one way here for black - to
get a playable interesting position he
played f3 which is also ok it seems this
is some very my mind very human news he
wants to give away this pawn to activate
the night you know this is quite similar
to what we saw before but now the F pawn
is missing so that night f4 or play
against their phone as possible Bishop
g2 and Knight f4 Black has sacrificed
three pawns now but it's very very
active this is a very strong night on f4
and I think that now souls decision is
it's very understandable he just he just
took the night he couldn't really stand
the side of this this piece any any
longer and just took it and yeah now
when when it takes with the e pawn which
is probably debatable um G takes seems
to be seems to be stronger and it's
still very unclear position
instance after 96 you have to analyze f3
again which seems to be enough for a
draw like this like this for instance
this should should lead to a draw again
bye-bye perpetual x' and the queen
enters after sacrifices something like
this is even losing yeah very very
complicated business he took with the e
pawn however and this seems to be
questionable after 96 Queen g7 here
white could have preserved I guess some
advantage by playing a queen - um Queen
to b6 for example this also it tends to
use the Queen for defense or get it to
default
he played oops
they played Queen before what illogical
at all attacking here and also
introducing the Queen D for idea that I
then I just just showed but against
Queen before when VD has a very direct
counter play and he found it but not too
difficult but of course still need to
play it f3 securing the breakthrough
rook takes and now he took on on h3 so
this is some is happening after all it
was a motif and in numerous lines and
now it is played King G - and he played
rook h6 rook edge form seems to be a bit
easier but still this is a playable move
went here and Queen b6
attending Queen d8 Queen f8 yeah this
has more than one idea one is certainly
to to enter but also in some cases you
can consider the the sacrifice so it's
very understandable why it's doing here
he's trying to get the Queen's off and
yeah like black exchanged and played
King g7 attending to to use the King 96
and rook h8
the room is needed to help in defense so
let's stay take a stop here bright has
three pawns for the exchange which is
really quite a lot but it seems that
those relatively um yeah not so
dangerous pawns at the moment there's
someone backward and they are not so
dangerous I mean it looks scary on paper
but it's not not not losing probably let
be five and here here it's it's a
question what like should do in fact
that vini was I guess a little time on
the clock it's ninety it's um it's move
39 here he took on c6 and this loses
straightaway he needs to do something
else I mean this one probably or okay
eight maybe look at it is the is the
tougher moves even and then he needs to
try to hang on with with this endgame
something like this for example and then
the king black has some chances to
defend it's not necessarily lost it's
certainly critical but it's something
that still needs to be played very
precisely by white and even then I'm not
sure it is winning the the problem will
also have a he took on c6 and after the
capture here white plate should be
formed and this is now quite simple he
threatens Bishop f5 and promotion so on
that has basically only rook c8
available to prevent that and after that
the simplicity pawn pushing up the board
and white will promote one of his Queen
set bones so nice win at the end for for
Wesley so I mean Nvidia really played
and good creative great game and he was
certainly very close to to get get
enough play to maybe get to draw to
perpetual here probably you should have
played drew cage for this is just a bit
more more active the endgame that that
he got is maybe as I mentioned still on
something you can try to defend but it's
not a very attractive task because you
can only draw off everything
yeah it was perfectly but you can easily
lose against the pants alright so I
saved the most important game in terms
of the overall standings for last and
this is Aronian playing coyoacán a you
know I really are having a great
tournament leading leading it with how
much is this CF plus five even I think
he's got plus five and kayaking is one
one point behind so a very important
game let's see what happens Aronian
playing wide in kayaking places very
very standard defense the Queen's Indian
it's his his pet opening for for ages
and in fact if we look at this she had
one of the typical main lines of the of
the Queen's Indian defense that both
players have quite some experience in
yeah this opening you could easily make
an sir beyond that that is hours long
because there are so many different
lines in general Black's play revolves
around playing c6 and d5 attacking in
the center we see that this is happening
and here we we reach them and isolated
sorry that hanging hanging paw
information in a way where white is
close to getting the hanging pawns but
he's got this pressure along this
diagonal so black has a hard time to
ever capture and c4 in fact we see that
this tension in the center is maintained
for quite a long while
castles 96 Bishop a4 in Knight a5 yeah
in fact all this has been played before
and more than once
curiously enough if we go to exactly
this position on this 18 we in the
database you could find a game where
kayaking was playing black here against
Peter Lake oh and I think it wasn't one
of those Grand Prix tournaments in Zook
and Switzerland one of the greatest
places to get to to play a chess
tournament because Zook in German it's a
John what means move so it's quite
fitting to the plate
there alright so this this has been
played before and now kayaking place a
new moon replace Queen to d6
which is meant to improve on 94 in the
mentioned game against Lagoon in the
game against liquid was also the case
that black was very slightly worse and
struggling a bit so 26 is it's
understandable that he's trying to
improve this is also one of the top
choices of the of the computer in fact I
do believe that this whole position yeah
this is just very very slightly
favorable for white due to the more
active pieces and the pressure on the
center we now see a slight
simplification took on f6 and took on d5
recaptures can you can check alternative
cm Knight takes e5 for example but after
that it seems that white is gaining upon
here this is saying something like this
check what will be a pawn up at the end
I think what what kayaking played was
perfectly okay
he just recaptured and now he's got some
pressure on e5 so white needs to yeah to
take care of that he took on d5 getting
a pawn and now Bishop takes on e5 there
are various possibilities here for
example here this also route 88 first
I'm using this rook to increase the the
central pressure lines like this for
example are not clear at all because the
pornea can easily drop due to the the
crash
the heavy pieces there were a number of
possibilities but what kayaking is doing
is this okay he just takes the pawn back
and this basically means after this that
we have like to have some more moves in
here if you look at this we see that we
have a completely symmetrical pawn
structure well besides the the g3 move
that is that is yeah unique for what
like a slope like g6 it's completely
symmetrical so play is mostly about
piece activity and quite often it means
that do you have enough activity to
let's say get a look on the seventh rank
or do you have enough activity to to to
win a pawn at some point and it's clear
that white is the one to dictate events
here because of the active minor pieces
here so black is the one to do to defend
here but it seems that while this is not
such a pleasant task like estilo came he
played Queen to g6
okay no Queen trade of course
so quite obvious g6 of course and ninety
five cents so white is trying to
activate his pieces as mentioned and now
with Roxy one increases the pressure on
c6 the next move seems to be one of the
critical points of this game it it's not
as mentioned a pleasant task to defend
blacks position but it seems to be
possible with the Moog f2e eight it's of
course it's very obvious move you you
certainly think about it activating your
your last PCM
the rukon f8 to e8 but the move that
probably irritated kayaking in his
calculation was I guess Queen to h4 this
looks very normal now getting this
threat into the mix and the big point is
that here black can really play g5 which
is a very ugly move but it's technically
justified black can afford it and white
really does not have a great reply here
the problem being that something had
this cat which looks nice at first is
just answered by King g7 black ignores
this bishop and now it gets very tricky
because black also has the opportunity
to play Knight to deform for example
just yeah now this is it starts to hang
in a way it needs to move at some point
so retreat and then 94 I now we see that
this is quite quite something this check
for example will regain the pawn chance
there's only king of one away check and
in this position it it seems to be
completely equal black must be still
slightly cautious because of this week's
square but unless is yeah really yeah
nothing has got down he should he should
draw him g5 is a very important resource
that you can easily misjudge know after
g5 there's still another line you need
to check what happens is what keeps
pieces on and threatens Bishop takes h7
here for example after that there's also
nice
before and here in fact Black has lots
of lots of tricky play available is also
putting some pressure on those
centralized pieces and note that this
diagonal with g3 is slightly weakened so
it's a complicated position where black
is enjoying fair chances rook fe8 is
probably the the move that that would
equalize here but it's not easy to judge
the consequences of a really ugly move
by g5 to judge it correctly the computer
is very unimpressed by white but I
understand that it's not easy for black
to find it
he played King to h8 getting out of the
possible checks on f6 but after Knight
takes b6 white of course wins upon of
course kayaking has seen that it's not
overlooked a simple move like 1936 but I
guess he thought that he gets enough
activity to to care to balance the game
out at the end yeah you see that Aronian
grabbed the pawn and now he played roopd
too so a very human decision giving away
a pawn for the active pieces and now
activating the rook note that what now
cannot take here because of Queen D
phone with a funny double threat this is
why Queen h4 was played looking at this
square and also swinging the Queen over
to the Queen side it's I must submit
that after rook takes what white got it
back
that's a couple of moles it's a very
obvious I think development white um has
this b3 phone here here it's very a
curious position after after Queen d2 I
think everything before was rather
rather logical or even obvious in this
position I really would have thought
that black should avoid the Queen trade
at all costs he played aged form
funny enough and after that Aronian
played Queen B - it seems that if I read
this correctly that in the post game
interview Aronian stated that he wasn't
sure that this is really a winning route
endgame the surprised me I mean of
course he's yeah it's not even fair to
compare it my endgame knowledge with
this but I would have I would have
really thought that with the look behind
the pawn and no particular special
features of the position that I should
be able to win and I'm surprised that
kayaking allowed that it's possible
though that instead of h4 if you play
something else that the b-pawn supported
by the rook is still enough to do to win
the game it's it's possible but I still
I'm surprised that he allowed the Queen
trade if we look at this I really don't
don't see much of a defense white will
advance to c3 the only somewhat distinct
feature of this position might be this H
pawn push we're like can try tubes to
invade but we see that in the game that
this is
really is so dangerous yeah here the
phone is already advancing and yellow
black went all the way to 2 H 3 but
after the capture and and therefore this
is not leading to two to two anything
much yeah it's already on v6 around here
I think black is is really lost the King
is quickly supporting the pawn and we
have a setup where the pawns are not
really dangerous black spawns
check yeah
note that after this the F pawn is not
dangerous at all as white always has
grew on the effort to stop it for
example if like no place f3 does just
king c7 chant something like that and at
the end the pawn is is being caught and
white wins easily with with the extra
book yeah a very tactical game at the
end but it seems to really get get get
to this critical position where rook f8
would have kept the balance after that
it's a very uphill struggle I mean maybe
there is a tougher defense but this is
already already very very difficult to
play it would be interesting if you have
more time on your hands to analyze
exactly this endgame position that black
allowed if it is really a flat-out win I
think white is very close to winning but
I'm not 100% positive that
the force twin need to be cautious with
very extreme statements like that even
if Aronian is not 100% sure it's not it
I really care cannot be shoe as well so
it's it's it's very very tough for for
black to defend so another very crucial
win for Aronian who's now almost Hazzard
in the back he's won at a half point
clear of Giri on who's on second place
and the only two rounds to go so Aronian
in excellent shape and if he continues
like that he certainly is the top guide
to watch for the candidates tournament
that it's not so far away as in in March
just starting in I think five or six
weeks if I'm not mistaken - - yeah - get
to know the new challenger for four
cards and later this year so um I think
again tomorrow is the rest day they have
really lots of rest days in this
tournament due to this location changes
so maybe tomorrow if I'm if I manage not
having so much time I'm going to show
one or two games from the B group which
is really interesting as well but you
see that the videos are very long only
with covering the the a group the the
Masters group I think it is called now
alright I hope you liked it thanks for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow
probably with the big group one or two
games bye